a few weeks ago I showed you how to use
ng rx entity adapt Paris today I'm going
to build on this concept and show you
how to use fire store as a persistent
back-end data source you might be aware
that angular fire version 5 has a new
state changes method which we're going
to take advantage of in this episode it
makes it possible to keep track of when
documents are added modified or removed
if you want an example of how this might
be used look no further than the
firebase console itself if we add a new
value to the database you'll see it
flashes green first one second and the
document itself is modified so it
flashes orange if we remove the property
then it flashes red the fire store web
console happens to be built with ng rx
which I learned by watching angular air
episode 135 so make sure to check that
out as well if you're new here click the
subscribe button and follow along with
the source code at angular firebase comm
to get started I'm going to first show
you how we have this app setup based on
the previous video starting with the app
module the main change we made is we
installed angularfire 2 along with
firestorm I'm also including the ng RX
effects module and in the root just
passing it an empty array if you're lost
at this point make sure to go back and
watch the ng RX entity video from there
I'm going to go into our pizza feature
module and I have a new file called
pizza effects that we're going to create
later we also import the effects module
here but call for feature and pass it
the pizza effects file the actual app
we're building is just a collection of
pizzas and the user has the ability to
asynchronously update them from a status
of cooking to delivered the thing that's
interesting is that this app is going to
listen for the state changes coming from
angularfire 2 and then use entity
adapters to update the local data store
currently I've queried all the pizzas
that have a status of cooking so if the
status changes from anything other than
cooking it should be removed from our
local data store if we update the status
from cooking to delivered you'll see
that it gets removed from the local data
store and that action is triggered here
and redux dev tools the key takeaway
here is that you'll always know how your
data is changing relative to the way you
queried it from firestore let's go ahead
and setup the ng RX actions that make
this possible
the first action is query eventually
it's going to make a query to Phi
store and listen to any changes that
happen to that data and from there we're
going to set up added modified and
removed it's important that you keep
these names consistent because they're
returned to us from angularfire - I also
want to show you how to update data on a
fire store document so we'll set up
actions for update and success each of
these actions will have a class that
implements the action interface and has
a custom payload that we defined in the
constructor the query action doesn't
need a payload but the added action will
return an individual Pizza object so we
can type that to our pizza interface
then modified and removed we'll also
follow the same exact pattern they
simply create a payload of a pizza
object the update action is a little
more interesting it's going to take an
entity ID as well as a partial piece of
data that we want to update on the
interface normally typescript wouldn't
let us do this but we can use the
partial type with our Pizza interface to
update individual properties on the
object the success action is only used
to show us when a successful update
operation has been completed so there's
no need to add a payload to it then the
final step is to export all these
actions as a single type now we're going
to jump into the reducer and I'll go
through the whole thing from top to
bottom so first we're gonna import the
actions we just created as well as a few
things here from ng rx then we'll define
our pizza interface which just has an ID
a size and a status which can either be
cooking or delivered then we can use
this interface to initialize our adaptor
this will give us access to a bunch of
helper methods to update the state
consistently from there we use entity
state to extend the main state interface
this ensures that our data conforms to a
specific format for entity and if you
have some initial data you want to set
as the initial state you would do that
here but for now I'm just going to leave
it blank now we're ready to build the
reducer function it takes the old state
as well as the action that's being
dispatched which will be one of our
pizza actions and then we'll set up the
switch statement here and the first one
we'll look for is added so whenever we
get a new item that's added we're going
to add one pizza to the state that will
add one new pizza to the stay
and keep track of its ID and everything
automatically for modified will call
update 1 then pass it the entity ID as
well as that changes that we want to
make then the same basic idea for
removed but this time we'll call remove
1 and it takes the ID as the argument
with just these three actions in the
reducer we can throw around all kinds of
different asynchronous events while
providing a ton of feedback about our
local data store that last step is to
create the selectors that allow us to
slice various pieces of the state that's
done by calling create feature selector
and then ng our X gives us a bunch of
built-in helper methods or you can
create your own to slice different
pieces of the state in this demo we're
only going to be using and select all
now we're ready to build the ng rx
effect the effect will allow us to
isolate asynchronous events so we don't
have to actually trigger those events
from inside a component in other words
component should only dispatch events
and select parts of the store they
shouldn't cause any asynchronous side
effects on their own we're also going to
be using the new ledyba operators from
rxjs five point five so that imports
syntax is slightly different as you see
here the first thing I'm going to do is
inject the actions as well as the
angularfire store library in the
constructor the most important effect
here is query and that's going to make
the query to fire store for collection
and handle the added modified removed
events that come from that collection so
first we call actions of type with the
query action that returns in observable
so we can pipe multiple rxjs operators
here which will make our code more
readable than it has been in previous
tutorials that i've shown you about ng
RX effects the next step is to make a
query to fire store so we do that by
calling angular fire store collection
and then we're going to only query the
pizzas that have a status of cooking
then to get an ng rx friendly observable
from fire store we call state changes
that returns an array of actions so
we'll map that down to each individual
action by calling merge map then we can
dispatch the correct action based on
what's returned from fire store so we'll
call pizza with the action type which
will be added modified or removed and
then the payload will be the actual data
that we update on the
cool store we want both the data and the
document ID so we can map those together
here in the object that's all there is
to it your local data store will now
stay in sync with the data in firebase
and you'll have a lot of flexibility for
managing those changes but we're not
quite done yet
I still want to set up one more effect
so the user can manually update data in
fire store this time we're going to
listen to the update action and when
that occurs will map it down to that
data payload that has the document ID as
well as the data that we want to update
from that point we call switch map and
then with the data that we want to
update we'll make a reference to that
pizza in fire store then the update
action is going to return a promise so
we're going to create an observable from
that promise to take care of that you
can do observable from promise and then
make the update inside of it and lastly
we'll map that down to the success
action once that promise resolves
successfully it also be a good idea to
catch errors here and dispatch an error
action but I'm skipping that part for
now we're almost done at this point we
just need a component for the end user
to interact with we'll go ahead and
import ng rx store as well as the
actions and reducer that we just created
then our actual observable will be an
array of pizzas the store is injected in
the constructor and it's typed to our
pizza interface we'll make the initial
query during ng on an it but first we'll
select the slice of the store we want
for our pizzas variable after that all
we have to do is dispatch the query
action and our front end is going to
have some buttons where the user can
update the state of an individual pizza
the update pizza method is an event
handler that will bind to a button click
and we can just dispatch the update
action with the corresponding payload
the HTML code is incredibly simple we
just loop over the array of pizzas and
then for each one we'll add that update
status button clicking this button will
trigger an asynchronous write operation
which will update the pizza from a
status of cooking to delivered now let's
go into the app and take a closer look
at what's actually happening here the
initial page load pulls the data from
fire store and then adds it to the state
in the entity format if you look at the
actions we first have a query pizzas
action and
we have for added events after that and
of course that gives us four pizzas on
the screen here as well
now let's see what happens when we click
the update status button we get three
actions here first the update and then
it's removed from the local store then
update success after the actual update
promise resolved so even though the
pizza wasn't removed from fire store you
still get the removed action because it
was removed from the local store you
could use that state change to toggle a
CSS class or show a toast message or any
other UI element you can imagine now
let's take a look at one more thing what
happens if we update a property on a
pizza from fire store or any other
client subscribing to this data you'll
see down here in dev tools we get a
modified action which tells us that the
data on the pizza was updated but it
still remains in our base query the end
result is that you now have a system
that will detect changes in fire store
and tell you exactly how they affect
your local ng rx store that's it for ng
rx with angularfire - if this video
helped you please like and subscribe and
if you want to learn more every week
consider becoming a pro subscriber at
angular firebase comm you'll get access
to exclusive content a free copy of my
book as well as a bunch of other
resources designed to help you get your
app off the ground thanks for watching
and I'll see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]